hi there steve kaufman
today i'm going to give you two videos
one video i'm gonna do with my goofy
french berean and i'll explain that and
why
and the second one will be my regular
video where i talk about my views on
language learning
the beret because in 2007 i was in
southwestern france the world rugby
championship was going on but we were
just
touring around but language learning is
all about
meeting people of different languages
because very often
you know we learn languages as a bit of
a lonely pursuit whether we're
independent learners or whether we're in
a classroom it's us and the language
and it's so much fun to connect with
other people
and to connect with
people who are learning some of the
languages we're learning or who are
involved in talking about language
learning and
the event to do that is the long fest
again the connection to french and
france or french and montreal
festival day long the language festival
in montreal august 25 to august 27
i'm gonna be there and i would like to
see as many of you as possible be there
as well
and if you buy tickets you can use a
coupon
code to buy these uh tickets and get a
discount if you put in as your uh
special access code call it
steve s t e v e
lower case uppercase mix doesn't matter
it's not case sensitive
s-t-e-v-e you will get a 25 discount and
you'll get the discount
over and above any other discounts that
you may be entitled to as a student or
or whatever it might be
uh i was at the last one in montreal
it's a wonderful occasion
montreal is a lovely city
and we have a tremendous group of people
coming
uh including stephen krashen
the wisest man in language instruction
in my opinion
and he'll be talking you'll have a
chance to schmooze with stephen crash
and and of course there will be alex
rawlings i mean richard simka the oly
richards
a girl a young little girl from russia
who's learned to speak seven languages
and speaks them very very well and her
parents and so a range of different
people i i can't list all of the
speakers i will leave a link to the
website
and i want you to go there and i want
you to see if you can't find the time to
come to montreal and if you do and if
you sign in with the access code steve
you'll get a 25 discount and i would
then be able to see you and i would look
forward to seeing you in montreal so
please sign up and come to montreal
francophone
trailer
so see you in montreal bye for now
[Music]
you